mi sono reso conto che su youtube
manchiamo soltanto noi nel fare
l'intervista doppia l'hanno fatta
praticamente tutti e quindi intervista
doppia nome lorenzo giulia cognome
ostuni penna bic man ray j
giulia verità le dà a una donna non si
chiede quindi lascerò questa incognita
22 anche se ne dimostro 16 da dove vieni
da roma che il presente
torino quanto sei alto 181 tanto le tue
fobie ho paura delle api per anni gli
fanno veramente succedeva non morire
tutti soffrono anche un po di vertigini
quindi i ragni mentre faccio al
paracadutismo come vi siete conosciuti
ma se non me lo ricordo non ricordo zero
e ci siamo conosciuti in agenzia siamo
abbiamo approfondito la nostra
conoscenza sul set del videoclip tu sei
di gabry ponte tre aggettivi per
descrivere l'altro allora nel simpatico
è un bel ragazzo è una persona sincera
pazza altruista viola pensi che fa vj
sia un bravo youtuber assolutamente sì
c'è pensi che giulia sia una brava
cantante se temo dovere di voi questo io
ci ho messo del mio poi chi di voi
guadagna di più io né sicuro no perché è
il più bello
no non so no certo come no no no io no
io chi è il più timido
io e lui è il timido dai sei dei mid o
chi bacia meglio è io ah beh io come
faccio a giudicare da sola nel vostro
bacio da sola quindi non lo so siamo
bravi entrambi milioni di persone mi
hanno visto in un bacio lungo e
appassionato nel videoclip di gabry
ponte come è stato baciare l'altro bello
cosa da capire
bello se una bella esperienza stata una
bella esperienza comunque n'era solo uno
erano di più
messi insieme come tosto scoop quante
volte volutamente sbagliato la scena ma
abbia amica se sbaglia una baciare tutto
spontanea tante troppe bacio alla
francese
se che fortino cosa hai pensato quando i
gravi ponte ti ha chiamato che figata
poi quando ho saputo pure che c'era
lorenzo detto triplamente che figata
cioè metto cafà per limone il video del
quale sei più orgoglioso ma è il terzo
in italia tutti i miei video clip
musicali soprattutto dietro di me se non
avessi fatto quello che fai cosa avresti
fatto
credo montatore video la cantante sempre
o facevo prima faccio adesso lo farò per
sempre in quanti sono i sette nani 7 mai
detto di otto come si chiamano cucciolo
mammolo brontolo è uno l'artri all arte
non mi ricordo proprio eolo mammolo
pisolo dotto non lo so il tuo cantante
preferito
michael jackson christina aguilera in
assoluto perché ci sono cresciuta poi
posso dire freddie mercury
il tuo attore preferito che angelina
jolie oddio kevin spacey il tuo colore
preferito rosso il viola vasca o doccia
e vasca basta ma ero montagna mare è
assolutamente pure se sto bianca come un
cadavere montagna fabri fibra o gigi
d'alessio fabri fibra
ma gigi io lo amo non si può fare
altrimenti gg di alluvione e anna
rihanna magari o mengacci chi non ha
idea di chi siano mi dici la capitale
della francia parigi parigi la capitale
della germania berlino e no dai non così
aspettano un bene
berlino la capitale della spagna e
madrid madrid
ciao detonati e una diffida a barcellona
mi dici la capitale di mosca mosca mosca
è una capitale mosca la capitale della
russia bravi mi faceva un po più stupidi
prova contare fino a 10 con la
numerazione binaria ma sei scemo ho
studiato anche informatica non lo so
binaria facciamo un giochino
quanto fa due più due fa quattro più 48
38 più otto feriti 16 più 16 20 qua
quindi 16 più 16 32 32
penso ad un numero tra 12 5 fatto fini
il numero 7 vero com'è possibile non è
possibile sta roba
o mio dio come l'altra vero stavolta vi
ho fregati fai un lutto è un'azienda
l'unico maschio che non ha la capacità
di dirottare a comando
questo era bello dondo micanti un pezzo
dell'ultimo singolo di giulia penna
dietro di me by aver fortuna ho capito
perché cammini sempre dietro ma perché
devo fare ste cose dai ea non ho ancora
capito perché cammini sempre dietro di
me
e poi un saluto all'altro ciao altro poi
un saluto chi ti sta guardando ciao a
tutti ragazzi ciao ragazzi non avete
visto questo video 20 ragazzi che sarà
l'intervista doppia mia e di giulia non
pensavo mai nella mia vita di fare un
video del genere è stato molto più
divertente di quanto pensasse in realtà
comunque ragazzi prima di concludere
direi di mettere il momento pubblicità
perché nell'intervista doppia c'è sempre
la pubblicità dopo potrebbe darsi che
ultimamente abbiate visto il mio
faccione sopra la scatola di un tablet
questo perché ultimamente sono diventato
sponsor dei nuovi prodotti di ciani che
si chiamano rispettivamente il mio tab è
il mio von siccome voglio fare vedere a
lisciani che sono in grado di fare una
pubblicità dove vi faccio vedere il
funzionamento del tablet a voi lo spot
[Musica]
mamma quindi spero sia chiarissimo come
si utilizza il tablet probabilmente lui
alcune di queste scene lo avete già
visto in giro su internet ma per quanto
riguarda la scena del tavolo almeno in
quella sono stato originale dai ragazzi
spero che i video vi serve aiuto io
conclude questo blog
intervista spot di come usare un
tagliere proprio vi sia piaciuto come si
è visto come un mi piace anche vari
social coniglio da descrizione mi guardo
in giro perché ogni volta un drone
telecomando eccolo trovato
fortunatamente alla nostra volta si
spera sera che si riscrive tecnici
vediamo un prossimo vito bella ragazza
[Musica]